the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok welcome to course design today how to
plan a course and avoid the pitfalls
that many courses fall into and then
I'll talk well we've in the past few
sessions we've seen some of the results
for example the misconceptions the rote
learning the lack of transfer and how do
you design a course so that your course
doesn't commit more of that and
contribute to that problem but instead
perhaps mitigates it and it's a
difficult problem so related to that
sort of flowing almost directly from
course design is that trip making large
changes to courses is politically very
difficult and several people have asked
me questions about that so actually the
penultimate session will be political
barriers to educational change so for
example the bed nizette experiment what
happened to Ben assets-- experiment and
why isn't it done more so actually I
went to the Manchester school board and
looked at all the Manchester New
Hampshire and looked at all the school
board minutes to see what happened from
the 1930s to see what happened so I'll
talk a bit about that talked about in
one of the structural obstacles to
change so that you know what you're up
against so that you can make strategic
slide choices and not gonna take
yourself shot at too much okay but
that's sort of a consequence of good
course design and that we'll do in the
penultimate session this time we'll talk
about what if you had your ideal world
what would you do so sort of a process
of successive approximation in the ideal
world what would you do and then in the
real world how do you get as close to
that as you can okay so today course
design
which is um how do you design a course
so that you avoid the main problems with
the traditional courses so now before I
say how do you design a course like that
let me review a bit we've seen some of
it in the previous sessions but what are
the problems with the traditional
courses
so the problems with the traditional
courses in broad outline are one rote
learning I think that's the most
fundamental problem
so we've seen many examples of that and
I'll just remind you of a few and I'll
show you a couple so I'll remind you of
a few just to summarize it in one second
and related to rote learning is that
there's no transfer okay so what are the
causes well come to that in a second but
for example what I mean by rote learning
so rote learning is the fundamental
problem and it actually causes this one
so if you really you learn by pattern
matching you're not going to be able to
transfer to a new situation unless
you've happened to by luck seeing that
pattern before but any really new
situation will be completely unfamiliar
and you won't be able to do it so the
examples
so the canonical example as I find it's
actually very helpful to have a
canonical example of what is rote
learning I think this is the canonical
example it's that ok so I have that
picture in my mind and the whole story
behind that picture is this one so this
is from ver timer again so you so
students are learning to find the area
of this parallelogram and they move that
triangle over there make a rectangle
they know how to find the area of the
rectangle so rote learning you can test
for rote learning by giving them this
picture writing the students who
understood who who didn't understand but
it's only seem like they understand they
take the triangle they don't know what
to do with it right so they can't find
the area anymore because it wasn't what
this reveals is that they didn't
actually understand what they were doing
they didn't understand that the purpose
of this procedure was to make a
rectangle because you know how to find
the area of a rectangle they thought
what you do is you chop off the left
triangle move it over there and then you
do some W times H right so operationally
it looks almost exactly the same but
cognitively underneath what's going on
under the hood not is something
completely different you find out when
students have done rote learning because
they can't do this problem so this one
so this is actually this has all aspects
of rote learning so if they can't even
do this problem they haven't even done
any learning but if they can do this one
but not this one they've done rote
learning okay so now if they haven't
done any learning that's a completely
separate problem generally not the
problem we've had we have problems but
students have done way too much learning
but it's all in the wrong direction so
that's one example have I shown you
folks I probably some of you the army
bus problem the army bus problem is very
amusing all right so there's so there
are eleven hundred twenty eight soldiers
and you have they have to be bused from
one base to another so this was actually
again it was another National Assessment
of Educational Progress problem so you
know it's given to a sample of about
50,000 high school students so it was a
huge study and there's 36 per bus that
you can take so the question is how many
buses so it's it's not a rocket science
question they're just supposed to you
know figure out how many buses to use
and maybe one is the right answer maybe
but it just keeps shuttling back and
forth let's just assume that's not know
what was looked for so I'll just give
you this okay so 11 28 over 36 is 31 and
1/3 so now I'm giving you that basically
to simulate the State of Mind of the
students because it turns out about 70
percent of the students I did this
division correctly so now there's
another 30 percent who didn't even learn
division correctly let's leave those
people aside of the 70% in other words
most of them who could do the division
correctly what did they say okay so take
take a minute find a neighbor and see if
you can predict what the students say
and what the distribution of answers is
so this is practice understanding where
students are coming
this is American high school student
okay so can someone suggest one answer
that people gave yes right so they'd so
that was one of the answers so actually
the way that in America at least when I
was in school you were taught to write
it as 31 are 12 so that means 31
remainder 12 which i think is a
completely broken way of doing things
but that's what we learned in school and
that's what some fraction students wrote
okay another answer 31 31 to round off
and another 132 would be nice right so
these in fact were the three answers and
they were all equally chosen except for
this was sort of slightly preferred to
the other so they were all roughly 25%
of this you know this is say 75% these
are all about 25% I think this was 28%
okay so this one was the winning one now
just stare at that for a minute
right what does that tell you tells you
that what it tells me is that the
problem had no meaning for the students
right they were again they done learning
so of the rote learning they done
learning there's no question about that
they'd learned how to divide right they
all could divide but they didn't know
what the hell they done right so if you
wrote oh yeah if you filled out in the
requisition form for the army yeah I
need 31 or 12 buses right where would
you do you probably be peeling potatoes
for the next week you know on KP duty so
this shows no meaning and what it shows
is that for most students further my you
know there was actually no me notes here
here again this also shows no meaning
but in a more sophisticated way than
this at least they thought about what to
do with the our twelve and they came up
with the wrong answer but they thought
about it and here we'll hope they
actually understood
so of the hundred percent 30% couldn't
do the division the roughly another
that's 20% it had no meaning another 30%
no meaning so now at 80% the only about
20% really understood what was going on
in a really fundamentally simple problem
right so that is a striking example to
me of how deep the road learning is
right it's the same as that problem I
showed you last time which was three
point zero four times five point three I
think it was right he had to multiply
and students had to choose the net
estimated they didn't actually have to
do that the calculation they have to
choose between one point six 1661 of
these four and it was just chance
basically right so again the number
system didn't mean anything to people so
it's a fine it meant it's really
fundamental it's really terrible and
it's been studied a lot so the problem
is not just an American teaching it's
across the world okay it shows up in
physics so the physics example I showed
you was this
so this is the bouncing ball
so it's stationary just for an instant
while it's bouncing and what everyone
drew is that there was normal force
equals mg and there's mg why well the
equals zero so there's several reasons
right here partly there was rote
learning involved because N was always
equal to mg and all these other problems
all right so they just trigger it off of
that the other one is that there's a
deep misconception right they actually
think F equals MV so that's the third so
here there's deep rote learning there's
no transfer what are the causes so there
you see one of the causes
it wasn't multiple-choice they just had
they were just given the problem just
like this and they yeah I know that I
don't think anyone who made a multiple
choice would ever have dreamt to put
that one on there yeah but I think it
was Freight like how many buses should
you order something like that I mean
this should come up with some integer
yeah yeah no it was a blank multiple not
a multiple choice it was a short answer
so that's that's how they could see that
they'd done the division correctly or
not and so all of the ones who done the
division correctly this is what you got
in question okay question
oh so this one was 84 I believe 83 or 84
and let's see what when with some of the
other so very timer was the 50s or the
40s those examples are the 40s oh yeah
you're right
well this every time I ask this one I
get the same results so this I've asked
between 1998 and 2009 and always got the
same results what are some of the others
so the other another one is cat logic
like capitana so that's a French study
so they asked students the question was
how do we know it's still a problem
today all right
so they've asked students there are 26
sheep and 10 goats on a ship how old is
the captain it's a good question the
problem is the answer right the answer
is that people answer 36 because they
have to stir the numbers around somehow
and get something right so that was done
in the 80s I believe yes
the existence of the problem wasn't
solved oh okay good question okay so I I
so I'm sorry I thought your question was
wasn't it all done long ago so it's not
a problem now oh yeah if there's so much
evidence to support the existence of a
problem why isn't it solved so I would
say there's two parts to that answer one
part is that a lots of people don't know
about this right so normally when you
teach so there's always sort of an
implicit contract which is that if I
don't ask you questions like that you
will reveal to me that I'm not teaching
any of these important things so for
example if you just take a regular
course it's actually possible to do all
the problems by pattern matching mostly
right so for as an example in physics
you'll have say you're doing circular
motion and someone will say well there's
a car going around a turn and the radius
of the turn is this and it's going at 30
miles an hour what's the force or in the
car has a mass M what's the force that
the road has to exert to keep it in the
turn
well you don't have to know anything
about circular motion all you have to
know is that there must be some formula
which has so let's look at the variables
that I just said there's f is the
unknown M is given V is given R is given
so you just flip through the book until
you find a formula with all of those
guys which happens to be equals MV
squared over R and then you just plug
everything in so you can do all those
problems without understanding anything
about centrifugal and centripetal for
example so 95% of students who can find
this formula with no problem if you ask
them well can you draw me a force
diagram did 50/50 on whether the forces
outwards or inwards you can ask them
things like okay a car is accelerating
where does the force come from the work
car is decelerating where's the force
come from oh you know the road that
seems really strange
it's true it's in fact from the road so
they have huge misconceptions even about
linear forces let alone circular forces
so the regular way of teaching actually
doesn't expose those yes yeah that would
help actually so I can say something
about how maybe I should have said this
last time I how I so the question was
what if standardized exams were better
and had higher level questions would
that help I think it would help and you
can still even do it multiple choice and
still have higher level questions so
here's actually a pretty striking
example I see if I can remember exactly
oh yeah so you ask students these are
young kids but it applies generally and
it's a question about how to design
tests hmm so you asked them I have a
piece of red cellophane and blue
cellophane and I put them together what
color do I get okay so now the question
isn't so much what what is the right
answer but what do you think students
say when you ask them that these are
young kids so take take a minute and see
if you can come up with what they say as
their answer their most common answer so
that you ask this as an open-ended
question you don't give a multiple
choice so fine yet talk to your neighbor
about that okay so
I'm I think it's actually very difficult
to predict what students actually say
and I'm willing to eat a chalk if anyone
well I don't know if I should say that
but that's a bit risky but let's just
chalk is pro safe but let's say I'm
willing to eat a chalk maybe with salt
and pepper
if anyone can actually figure out what
the students actually said a moon the
main thing they say because it's really
really counterintuitive oh yes oh go
ahead
okay so reddish blue is one thing yep so
that's one answer they give yep yes
Brown yeah that's probably good point
and say that red and reddish blue is
like violet yeah but if they're young
enough they might not know the current
color violet they might or purple yeah
okay so violet purple yes yellow came
I'm still safe so they do say all these
I don't know about yellow you know all
of them pick up but they say most of
these things I'm so far safe for my
chalk major yes blue okay yes that would
be nice yeah yeah
oh I gotta eat my chalk yeah so does it
matter which one's on ya which they say
particularly say which one's on top
can I have salt with that see it's so
red that is in fact the main question so
now why do I bring this question up well
so the normal way you'd make a multiple
choice question is you just okay you'd
ask the question yourself you'd think
well what are the plausible answers
you'd come up with you know many of the
choices here and you'd put them down to
the multiple choice and you never think
of putting this one there so one way to
actually design the questions is that
you first do it with a pilot group with
a short answer and then you make your
multiple choices based on the main
misconceptions that they have okay so
now what's the obstacle when you do this
the obstacle when you do this is you get
this very funny item response curve so
the item response curve is the following
so the item response curve you get so at
rittany
okay so this is on this axis is the
students overall grade and this is the
so you have a quite a test say of 50
questions or whatever and this is their
overall grade on this axis and this axis
is their probability of getting a
question light on one particular
question correct so now a usual a normal
question is something like you know that
if they don't know anything they have no
chance of getting it right
you know maybe they have some monkey
line level over here so let's call it
something like that okay but these kind
of questions actually have a very
different shape their shape is
it's shaped like a J in K so what
happens is that so this is the good
questions
I'll call I think they are much better
questions but they get this shape so
what happens is when the students are
just guessing they're somewhere down
here but as they start to think about it
and learn more then they fall into the
misconceptions right so they actually go
down whereas before so they're actually
can even be below chance and then only
when they really understand things is
they get up here
so now what happens what happens it's
tips for example if the SAT ever
contains a question like this they just
throw it out they say oh this question
does not measure how good a student we
have it's actually skewed it's all
messed up so you throw it out so these
normal the standard ways of making
standardized tests actually throw out
all the good questions and all you're
left with is these kind of questions all
right so I actually saw an example of
this in Cambridge which was so you
remember the rolling down the plain
question that I showed you I think last
week or the week before so they're
rolling down the plain question is an
intuitive question is qualitative it's
hard in some it's you can if you try to
calculate a kind of stuff you'll get
yourself in a knot unless you know
exactly what you're doing but if you
reason about it intuitively you can do
it quite well ok so that question was
then put on the end-of-year exam for the
sophomores and the examiner said well
actually this question was not a good
question because it didn't measure who
were the good students were so what they
meant was that the good students
actually sometimes did worse on that
question than the not-so-good students
so they said ok we're just gonna throw
that question out I mean they didn't
throw it out that time but we're not
gonna use questions like that next time
so again here you had a good qualitative
question and it didn't measure the good
student so it didn't give them what they
wanted so they threw it up so if you
designed a quite test like that you're
gonna fill it with questions that are
just sort of low on Bloom's taxonomy and
you're but it doesn't mean you have to
do it that way so if you want to make a
test that is higher on Bloom's taxonomy
and testament
inception qualitative reasoning
intuitive reasoning the way you do it is
you do it
short answer first put the main
misconceptions down and you just have to
be willing to live with this kind of
curve how do you tell who the good
students are well I mean it's a it's a
reification that's going on I mean
there's this idea that there's such a
thing as a good student and just because
you call it that doesn't mean there is
such a thing so you need some definition
so like for example what is Ikey
what is IQ the definition is it's what
IQ test measured that's the only I would
say valid definition of IQ test so here
good student meant doing well on the
standard problems now I don't think
that's a good definition of a good
student but that was what that is the
implicit definition in most courses so
to answer your question it's the
standard way things have done the
implicit definition that makes it so
hard to change the rote learning but
also so hard to even see that it's going
on and then the other half of your the
answer is that and when you do try to
change it you find all these political
obstacles and that's we're going to talk
about it in the penultimate session but
for example people downstream and one
question was raised about this and the
questions the next courses will say well
you didn't teach them X right suppose
you say oh my god I'm teaching them
sophomore mechanics and they don't know
Newton's three laws well I could just do
the Euler's top and the Herpa loads and
they're pole hoods and all of that stuff
and gyroscopes and all this complicated
stuff which is sort of a nonsense if
they don't understand Newton's laws or I
could actually sort up their
misconceptions on Newton law well
suppose you take time to do that well
then they haven't learned what the
purple load is right so who knows what
the her pollute is so I sort of remember
a while ago but no even even I every I
taught the course and I hardly remember
but the next downstream course will say
they didn't know the herp load you know
because you spend time on Newton's laws
so
that's the political problem so you have
to then somehow get the people
downstream to see that this is a serious
problem that we can only build sand
castles in the air for so high before
they collapse because the air can't
support that much and then that's what
I'm going to talk about in the
penultimate session question
goodbye Omega students you don't wanna
know
well it's so the question is which
question you use does depend on the
purpose as a test it does but I think
you do you absolutely need these kind of
questions or you're not actually
evaluating the right thing so if you
only put these kind of questions in
you're not exposing any misconceptions
so you're actually not evaluating some
of the important questions about what
the students understand because you'll
never for example if you just give them
colors on this question you'll never
realize that that's what they're
thinking about so actually you're just
evaluating can they give you one of the
pre prescribed color answers but that
actually isn't necessarily mean that
they understand so you're not actually
evaluating their understanding so the
evaluate understanding you do need
questions like this and should you
punish them for being down here no
that's the other part of it if they're
down here that means they're thinking
about it so if you then grade them and
they came down here you say oh you did
really badly no actually you're down
here that means because you're thinking
about it you got caught by the
misconception but that's the only way to
sort out the misconception you have to
go beyond it okay other questions and
then we'll take a break
okay so it is 10:05 actually according
to that clock plus an hour so 9:15
according to that clots at 10:15 see
everyone back here take a short
ten-minute break just says if it were
two 1-hour classes with the ten minute
break and then I'll put the feedback
sheets in the corners so when you come
back just make sure you grab a feedback
sheet okay so before we talked about the
problems with what Morse courses do and
how Road learning is a primary product
and as a consequence of that there's no
transfer to new situations so the
knowledge is very brittle so what are
the causes and what can you do about it
so just briefly the causes I mean partly
are no account is taken of the
misconception students have so new rote
learning is piled on old misconceptions
because by definition learning is going
to turn into rote learning if there's no
understanding and meaning given to it
just like the eleven twenty eight
divided by 36 is 31 are 12 so no account
is taken of what students have rote
learnt and what they've really
understood because the way the course is
normally taught those ideas those
cognitive conceptions aren't exposed in
the normal run of the way the course
happens and another is so that's
directly related to the problem but
another one is that the applications are
very narrow
so because the applications in the class
are so confined to the same area it very
easy to produce rote learning and so I
have a I keep saying how pictures are
the way to understand everything so I
have a picture for that so I show
everyone this picture and if you keep
this picture in your mind it'll give you
a guide for how you should make problems
and what examples to choose so suppose
there is some idea you'd like to teach
talking a bit about why you'd like to
teach an idea at all
but some idea you want to teach and you
have a clear conception of this idea for
example maybe the idea is something like
DNA is the you know fundamental unit of
information and living systems okay well
that means something to you but to the
students it doesn't actually mean
anything you need to give them examples
so you giving them an example or related
one is you have some idea which is a
dimensional analysis right you want to
give them an example of doing it because
just stating the Buckingham PI theorem
for them doesn't really help them you do
an example can we now picture yourself
back in the student mind what did the
students see well they don't have this
idea as a separate unit yet because
they're still students and the purpose
of the course is to teach that so they
haven't got it yet so they have this
merger of idea and example together okay
so they see this big package and have
trouble making that division between ID
and example in other words between
transferable idea and thing that was
particular to the situation so of course
what do you do you give them another
example so the normal way it's done is
here's your second exam
so there is a second example but now
again from the students point of view
there is still quite a big overlap
between idea plus example one an idea
plus example two so that overlap is what
they if they intersect the things
mentally in their head see what's common
they still get a lot of stuff that's
beyond just the idea for example if you
do a bunch of dimensional analysis
examples related to entropy then they'll
think oh dimensional analysis is a way
of solving entropy problems okay so here
that overlap is too big so what do you
have to do
but more examples and where should they
be in this space yeah way around right
so you should make an example over here
right so this example has very little
intersection with the other example okay
so here this one and this one and this
one they all have very little overlap so
now the overlap among all three is
pretty much just the idea but think how
different that is from the way most
courses are designed by most courses the
examples you know you'll do 18 problems
of the ideal gas law you'll do 18
integration by parts you'll do 18
solutions of first-order differential
equations you'll solve 18 ion channel
problems with a Nernst equation all of
those actually don't teach you the
fundamental idea to be able to transfer
it so that's another cause see that the
applications are too narrow so you have
to choose your applications as widely as
possible and this makes teaching very
hard because it means you can't really
yes question
skills so I mean in terms of like
broadening the way of I think that's
right so the oral so the suggestion was
that oral exams actually in general is
true are much better way of evaluating
whether the student understands or not
it was very disconcerting for the
students because I think I said this
last time basically in an oral exam as
soon as you student understand something
you ask something else so you're like
okay they know that let me ask about
something else so the student feels like
they're never talking about something
they know but that's the purpose of it
so yeah an oral exam like a PhD
qualifying exam forces transfer that's
what you're checking for and the PhD
qualifying exam so if you do things like
that in the undergraduate course that's
setting a goal of transfer that this is
one of the goals of the course you'll be
able to use these skills in new
situations I'm going to ask about then
of course to be fair you have to give
them practice in doing that you can't
just give them regular problems and all
the sudden give them an oral exam which
they now transfer to new thing they'll
just hit a brick wall but it helps you
in designing the course so I'll put the
backward design exam a diagram up again
to show that process so here you want to
choose from as wide a pasta set as
possible and generally that's not done
so I wanted to read a couple of
selections from the Eric experiment
about what happens in class so I know
you had a choice of reading so who chose
the Eric experiment which I thought was
I thought they were all fascinating so
if you remember there was a couple
quotes from Eric himself so Eric for
those who didn't read it Eric was a non
physics student who took a summer
session physics course freshman physics
course and recorded I think he was a
philosophy major
and he recorded his impressions of what
it was like to be in a physics class so
that's actually you get a quite a
different view of what a physics class
should be when someone from outside
comes sort of like this diagram all over
again right and he said the class
consisted basically of problem solving
and not of any interesting or inspiring
exchange of ideas
the professor spent the first 15 minutes
defining terms and apparently that was
all the new information we were going to
get on kinematics then he spent 50
minutes doing problems from chapter one
he was not particularly good at
explaining why he did what he did to
solve the problems nor did he have any
real patience for people who wanted
explanations
you know the why the what were the ideas
why would you do it this way rather than
that way those weren't generally part of
the course so by not making them part of
the course you're actually pushing
towards their rote learning and that I
doesn't mean that there are not all
these interesting questions so later on
in the selection he says well actually
you know I wonder about all the names of
physicists give but there's no space to
ask those questions in class he says
whom action-reaction that's Newton's
third law that presupposes a
cause-and-effect relationship which
implies duration but in action in
physics actually action-reaction Hymas
happen simultaneously so those are the
kind of questions that get away that
he's asking himself Erik the student
that get away from rote learning but the
structure of the class doesn't encourage
anything like that right so whatever and
the only reason he has time to think
about that is he's not actually kind of
just survived the class he's sort of
going in as an experimental student
whereas the students were just trying to
survive the class if any thoughts like
that occur to them they just say forget
it no time to think about that have to
solve the 10 problems on the end of
chapter 3 right now so those are the
causes what do you do about it well
there are several principles of design
so the last time I talked about two
principle organizational principles
these singles and systems model of how
to teach a course so this was the
teaching equation so this is the output
what students can do so you choose that
you also have to understand students
students students thinking and then you
figure out your teaching given what
given what you want them to be able to
do and how students think and the
misconceptions how people learn visual
for by examples diagrams like that how
should I teach does that give you an
overall structure for course design the
other structure which is quite similar
is backward design
so backward design you you invert the
normal order so the so the first to the
highest level in backward design is
that's the end over there so this is a
hierarchical structures basically you
choose your course goals you find ways
to make them operational so in other
words how would you measure for example
being able to solve Newton's laws
problems in design bridges that for
example might be one of your goals well
you would actually give them some
bridges to design things like that
and then given that you want them to be
able to do that wouldn't you in class so
this was last time that's this time and
this is next time and as I said before I
start here just because I find this is
at the right level balance between
concrete and abstract so we did that
last time but now we're here how do you
choose course goals and that the paper
by Middlebrook so who read Middlebrooks
paper a few people okay so if you
haven't read it I didn't want to
overload you with reading but I think
it's also a brilliant paper and I know
Middlebrook because he was my teacher at
Cal Tech and I took the course that he
describes in the paper and he identified
a fundamental problem and a fundamental
solution to it in other words how do you
choose the goals and I myself have
actually come to pretty much the same
conclusion through years of hard
experience
so this is all to answer what do you do
about it
which is you choose course goals such
that they will the course itself will
produce transfer so let me explain the
problem that made a Middlebrook
identified and what his solution is so
this is his particular class is a analog
circuit design class and generally the
way analog circuit design is taught is
you have a circuit and you ask the
students to analyze it for example you
give them a circuit that filters out
high frequency noise for example in an
audio recorder in a CD recording studio
and you analyze it and you you see that
its behavior does do what is its
behavior okay throw a high frequencies
okay so now that's the general
run-of-the-mill you'll just get tons and
tons and tons of problems like that and
you learn ways of analysis that allow
you go from here to there but then what
happens when the student graduates what
happens is what Millbrook calls they
fall off a cliff so either they go into
graduate school or into a company but
either way what happens is they're
actually given that somebody says well
actually I need a circuit that doesn't
cost too much and but uses a is quite
exact and cuts off all frequencies
beyond 22 kilohertz and doesn't mess up
the frequencies below 20 colors this is
actually a real problem that's how you
need to do that to record an assistant
of people who developed a CD standard
had to make something like this so
basically you're making any quota
anti-aliased filters so I want that now
here the problem is that the student has
learned methods of analysis that cannot
be inverted for example one method of
analysis is you have a circuit you just
simulate the thing you just feed it to
your computer which does all the
analysis for you on an analogy for that
if someone gives you a function to graph
you could use your graphing calculator
to see what the graph looks like but
suppose someone says well I want a graph
that looks like this the graphing
calculator can't answer that question so
they've learned methods of analysis that
are not invertible in case so they're
actually useless because the real world
problem is exactly opposite of the
school problem the school problem the
circuit is to start in the real world
the specification is the start so to
have any hope of going from there to
there now this is a one-way arrow is
like a diode you need to act a different
method you need to learn invertible
methods of analysis so if you have
invertible methods of analysis you can
go both ways so and that this problem I
think is central to many many many many
courses not just to this particular
analog circuit design course
so you so then what Middlebrook slowly
evolved to was not just teaching
invertible methods analysis but he made
those the foreground of the course as he
described I found in teaching this stuff
for a long time I've actually had to put
names and words to ideas for the
students to get hold of them this came
about because for a long time I taught
by example I used a lot of methods
saying we're going to look into the
properties of a certain circuit and I
would use some shortcut method or trick
that I thought was a neater way to do it
and I just showed them this without
actually emphasizing the method that was
fine but when they did the homework
problems in exams their minds just
automatically reset to the old way of
doing it so that didn't work very well
and I finally realized I had to give
names to these things and those are the
names that he introduces in the paper so
those names some of those are specific
to analog circuits some are general
but it's the giving of names that is the
central secure so you give names to the
big ideas in the course and you don't
just use them in passing but you make
them the focus of the course so let's
see
so in answer to what should the course
goals be roughly speaking take questions
about that because it's very different
from how it's normally done
so if you look for example at a biology
course it might be organized by saying
cell biology organized by the organs
organelle you know the little system
inside the cell but those aren't
necessarily transferable to anything
except that particular subject a physics
class might be organized by a whole
bunch of kinematics problems and
dynamics problems but a big
organizational principle that is
implicit there but isn't said is that
well actually what we're doing is we're
approximating down to something simple
enough that we can do that's an
organizational principle that you can
transfer but that's never said it's just
implicit if you look at chapter one the
simplest systems are simpler and then
chapter two they get harder maybe they
have two dimensions in them in Chapter
five they have two particles in them and
then chapter 7 they have n particles in
them right so it's this process of
successive complication and the
beginning part of it where we simplified
real world things into just one particle
moving in one dimension at constant
acceleration that was never told to the
student so the transferable principle
just went straight by them well because
we never made it explicit so you have to
if you ever have want to have any hope
of teaching these ideas you have to make
them explicit and give them names in
giving things names is absolutely
essential to have any chance of learning
them and this was known in all the you
know the old legends right the gods did
not want the mortals to have names for
the gods right because it would give the
mortals too much power over the gods so
the gun you know some gods were he who
has no name and that's maybe only the
high priest knew the name well you don't
want to be the high priest ready you
want to share the names with the
students and that involves a lot and a
lot and a lot of thinking and that's
where most of the work and course design
goes is figuring out those main ideas
these transferable goals and ways of
reasoning that today's students can use
no matter what they do and then to teach
them need
have it from as wide a set of examples
as possible so for example to give you
an illustration when I teach dimensional
analysis the which is the idea then I
want I want them to be able to use it
wherever the first example I forget
whether it's the first or second I sort
of flip it around the first example is
in economics because you can find a lot
of you can identify a lot of bogus stuff
in economics like because it has the
wrong dimensions so I want them to see
it there the second example is solid
geometry volumes of tetrahedrons and
cones and things and then we do sort of
a more standard physics one so I want
them to see the broad sweep of this idea
so that the idea comes clear so the the
thing to do is to identify large ideas
so these okay so to practice choose
right now a course in your own mind that
either you are interested in teaching or
or teaching now or would like to teach
and see if you can come up with some big
ideas for that course okay so just to
practice of what some big ideas are and
I will show you as an example the large
ideas for mine just to give you an idea
what they are I'll show you the tree for
my approximation course just so you can
see what level these ideas kind of live
at so the whole course is designed
around how do you deal with complex
problems and how do you handle the fact
that the world is really messy and I
broke that down into either you manage
it
where you throw it away yeah those are
still too high level to actually do
anything with but I wanted to organize
the big ideas as well so you can manage
it by dividing conquer reasoning so
subdividing into smaller problems or you
can make abstractions abstractions is
basically the process of giving names to
things which is what we're talking about
now to throw away complexity you can
either do it losslessly so this is
methods of reasoning that find
complexity isn't there but look like it
was there and get rid of it so symmetry
is the number one and examples of
symmetries and proportional reasoning
and dimensional analysis so those are
all lossless ways they don't actually
cost you anything if they work they make
your life so much easier and you haven't
thrown any information away or you can
make lossy compression so you can do
extreme cases look at only the simple
cases of things so you're throwing out
information or you can make spring
models so even though things aren't like
chemical bonds you say well they're just
like spring so that's a very useful but
lossy way or the final one is you can
lump so you can lump changing processes
into one for example a rect a curve you
want to find the area under the curve or
replace it by one rectangle so that
general pattern are those are what I
found are the most useful ways of
dealing with complex problems so these
are the big ideas in that course and the
whole course is organized that way and I
show this tree now you know once a week
usually just so people know where they
are
so now depending on the course what
stuff you have in your Big Ideas will be
different but I just want to give you an
idea of what some large ideas some
structuring principles are and then the
course itself is actually organized unit
one unit two three four five six seven
eight so what I found is just like
Middlebrook found that not only do you
have to give names to the things but I
found that I had to actually organize
the course around them rather than
organizing them around the topics that
they apply to if I really wanted the
techniques the ways of reasoning to
transfer ok so questions about what
these large ideas these reasoning
principles are what kind of things to
look for yes the course is called the
art of approximation in science and
engineering I so it actually it's carte
blanche to talk about anything all right
so that's why these are probably higher
level objects then in most courses which
will be narrower but even there like for
example in physics in intro physics one
of the core ideas is successive
approximation right and that's not
brought out normally but you could bring
it out you could say look we're using
successive approximation again or here's
the structure of the course so that it's
plain for the student does that help ok
so pick that course in your mind and
talk to your neighbor and see if you can
come up with say two or three large
ideas and now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna put them on the board the
reason being is that you'll find that
people's big ideas and large ideas from
other courses you'll be able to use in
your course you know not every single
one but many of them that's almost by
definition what makes something a large
idea that it's not just limited to that
course so it helps to see what other
people's are okay so I'll make some
space on the board to draw those up
so I'll give you a chance to develop
your list farther in the homework oh I
should say something about the homework
which is that you guys are all grad
students or almost all of you you're all
taking the course for fun it's kind of
pointless to me to police whether you're
doing stuff or not but all the same I
will give you an assignment to do and
I'll just trust that you'll do it which
is to work with each other on making
large ideas for a course and then
figuring on examples for those large
ideas so basically a sketch of a course
design and the reason to do this
starting now and also later is that
basically that is the hardest work of
course design once you've done that
everything else sort of flows you know
the syllabus writing all that stuff just
flows but if you haven't done this
you're just kind of spinning around you
don't actually know what you're doing
it's really hard to actually figure out
how you should start or what you should
do so big ideas any big idea in any
course ok separation of scale so that
behavior at one scale and another scale
you can often separate them and analyze
them differently and without interfering
with each other ok separation of scale
so that for example I've seen that done
in neurobiology it's done in physics all
the time so in neurobiology the calcium
flux the calcium concentration changes
slowly so you do the calcium
concentration separate from say the
sodium and the potassium which is done
with the action potential spikes so
separation of scales very important
principle across many fields yes
equilibrium
so right so equilibrium right away you
can see if you really want students
understand the value of equilibrium you
have a whole set examples to use to
steal from right you can use chemistry
physics mechanical engineering you can
they all have slightly different senses
the equilibrium statistical mechanics
but there's some core idea that's the
same and so it also is an argument for
team teaching we're actually talking to
colleagues from different fields to
steal examples from them yes yep okay so
identifying part so identifying a
scientific question and how to start
studying it yeah
identifying and studying right and
there's many things that are common them
across many fields and there's many
things that are different in each field
and you can actually very fruitful I
could imagine a really fruitful
interesting you can almost teach a whole
class on this actually that sounds kind
of fun you could teach it history of
science class and assign me the
questions that were identified how they
were studied what principles still are
done today you could have people read
papers really across many fields and see
you know read the intro and see how they
would study that question so what
questions there are yes sure pardon
residents right residents you can have a
field day with right it's in electric
circuits it's in mechanical systems you
know the earth-moon system the tides are
driven almost on resonance by the moon
and the Sun resonance is everywhere it's
in mechanical systems there's beautiful
films you can show of the Tacoma Narrows
Bridge the I think the London Millennium
footbridge as well that hit by resonance
so resonance another very transferable
idea yes okay so how did you how to
build models right and that's something
that there are general patterns to it
and some of its specific to a particular
course but their general patterns and
that's something the students can use no
matter what they do later
right that's what whenever you go to a
new field so there's a Nobel Prize
winner at Harvard Walter Gilbert
so he's worked in I think chemistry
physics and biology or many in different
fields hidden he said oh yeah whenever
you go to a new field there's only a few
key ideas in that new field and the hard
work is figuring out what those are but
that's what you have to do so that is
one of the transferable skills as well
others yes
okay so communication right if you can't
communicate you haven't solved the
problem and which reminds me of my
Caltech students when I I had them keep
a journal and then I told them I wanted
them to explain the journal they like
but I said on the homeworks I want you
to explain your reasoning so that it
reads it's not just hence and Gus and
therefore and they said well why do we
have to do that
you know we're physics students I said
well later on you're gonna have to
communicate your answers to someone they
said oh we'll just hire someone who does
that so then I said to them well how are
you gonna explain it to that person how
will how will they know I said oh you're
gonna explain it to them I said oh so
you are explaining something I said oh
no no we did something he said oh well
actually that person will understand it
already
so then I said to them well so that
person understands it already and can
communicate it and you just understand
it who are people gonna turn to right so
only then did they Bree that it was a
good thing actually right problem said
so they could communicate right so
that's something you can teach in any
field and a cross field you can look at
scientific writing you could look at
writing scientific papers couldn't look
at giving presentations doing it on
problem sets communicates you can have
students exchange problem sets with each
other
you can't understand the other problem
set clearly wasn't communicated other
transferable ideas yeah coordinates yeah
so coordinates and it's also a fun to
make this kind of list because you start
to see commonalities and they start to
suggest other ones so when you say
coordinates I also think oh yeah that's
a general example of representations so
there's different so this is probably
what you man is coordinate
representations what you're thinking of
but you can also think of the general
idea of choosing good representations
for solving particular problems like for
some problems the symbolic
representation may be right and some
there's a pictorial representation you
want to use in circuits the time domain
representation or the frequency domain
representations of coordinates put dot
dot dot to say that almost leads to the
next one
which is representation in general
others yes symmetry
yeah symmetry incredibly powerful yep a
dream and then you're next yeah okay so
linearization and that is of course also
huge I mean symmetry is used in almost
every field linearization basically you
can't do anything that's nonlinear so
every field does linearization so that
core idea will be beautiful to convey
that yes okay errors how do you deal
with errors they're common principles
probability theory statistics that deal
with errors in any field what are those
well that's what you want to understand
so you can move to any other field I'll
put a dot dot here so symmetry another
one that's related to symmetry its
conservation a new thirst theorem is
that every conservation law come
responds to a symmetry and vice versa I
think I've stated that correctly but
they flow from each other so actually I
do conservation here as part of symmetry
so let me stop the list right there just
to say that right away so I let me put
the other one which I talked about
before which is successive approximation
that you don't want to solve a hard
problem all at once it's sort of like
divide and conquer but you want to try
solve it approximately and then less
approximately then less less
approximately nice so you get closer and
closer as close as you need that's a
general principle of engineering design
as well so these just to show you that
all of a sudden you thought of a whole
bunch of examples and probably you can
use that in any course you take so now
you all have like eleven right now I'm
not saying you have to use all eleven in
your course but you can start the three
structure courses around those ideas and
make them explicit and choose which you
think are the most important in your
field and the ways of thinking and
illustrate them with things from your
field but nearby
as well okay so this this evening I'll
post a reading for next week and I'll
post a short assignment basically to
continue this line of thinking just to
give you some more practice in course
design and fleshing it out farther but
that what you've done is the key step
the card a step to course design so if
you could fill out the question sheet as
always very helpful and also there was a
question before that could I make sure
to list on the website things I
mentioned in class yes I should do that
so if I could request people to if you
have in your notes any of the books that
I mentioned in class we didn't put on
the website if you could email me those
I will put them on the website so as a
sort of divide and conquer approach so
I'm sure actually collectively you have
all of them
okay so just when you're done but you
can put the sheets up here and then
outside of that door
we'll have office hours as usual so that
the next class doesn't get delayed by us
being in here